what's going on guys this morning the
spoilers for black clover chapter 267
came out
and it dropped one of the biggest
bombshells the series has had for a long
time now
now on sunday i'll be doing a live
reaction to the official chapter release
for both black clover and my hero
academia so follow me on twitch if you
want to see that
but today i'll be focusing on one
element of this chapter
and kind of theorizing what it means
specifically i'm talking about
asda's mother who makes an official
appearance
in the final page when the anti-magic
devil remembers something about her
throughout the chapter astor and the
devil had been doing battle
in accordance with this devil binding
ritual thing that uh
they've been set up in the last chapter
and astor tells the devil during this
new chapter
that he isn't evil just because he's a
devil and this causes the devil to have
a flashback
and we briefly see a shadow of astor's
mom standing next to the present-day
astar following that we get a full page
of his mother which you can see on
screen
and the reason the devil remembers her
in this moment is because aster what
asta said to him
was very similar to what astor's mother
had also said to him
to be more precise according to the
rough translations
she says to him that he's not a bad guy
tabata has given us a million and one
clues as to why this is asda's mother
right here
firstly her shirt is the exact same as
it was in chapter 242
when astor was fighting dante and we got
this flashback to a bloodied person
this person had their hand outstretched
in some kind of dark flashback
and said the words my dear son and
obviously this is
presumed to be astor's flashback yeah it
was heavily implied then that this was
asked his mother
and now we see this character here with
the same clothes
it's interesting to note that this
flashback back in chapter 242
it was only triggered the moment gauche
was impaled by dante
and given the blood around her stomach
is it possible that a similar thing
happened to her as well
and the reason it was triggered is
because you know it's kind of like deja
vu for
asta i think it's possible
the next point that confirmed it for me
that this is asda's mother
was really really subtle so this random
strand of hair at the top of her head
i mean we've seen this from astor on
many an occasion
and you know when tabata was designing
this character
he didn't need to give her this it was
definitely something he added to confirm
it
beyond a reasonable doubt that you know
this is who we think it is
her wide eyes are also pretty much
identical to asters
and in every way astor is the spitting
image of this woman
um now thinking about her clothing she
doesn't have
any royal clothing you know it seems to
be pretty standard standard outfit
um something you would expect a commoner
to wear and the background is really
nice and scenic which implies that this
is not the spade kingdom
because as we know the spade kingdom is
famous for its harsh and cold
environment
so to have such you know luscious trees
it probably
is probably not the spade kingdom when
you compare these robes to the
typical heart kingdom citizens it
doesn't really match
and i think the same you know the same
goes for the spay kingdom um
their outfits don't really look like
this either so that just leaves the
diamond kingdom and the
clover kingdom if she was killed by
dante as i suspect
then it's possible that happened whilst
he was still a soldier in the spay
kingdom army
and therefore he was maybe visiting
other countries during war
if that did happen it would likely be
sometime shortly after
uh she had given birth to asta because
you know both astor and yuna were
dropped off at the village on the same
day
but from yuna's backstory we know that
you know he was he was alive
well before he was dropped off at the at
the church so the same is true for astra
as well he could have been
a baby for a few weeks for a we know but
regardless the info in this chapter
raises
so many questions about the anti-magic
devil itself
mainly the fact that this confirms to me
at least that the devil was
alive in human form not that long ago
i mean if asda's mom was having a
conversation with it
you know it stands to reason that he was
not a devil at this time just casually
in the forest having a chat with aston's
mom like he was probably a human being
when she was having this conversation
back in chapter 246 we got this panel of
astor's devil
just having insane thoughts thinking
about how much he wants to kill dante
which was a level of hatred we'd never
seen in this show before
not even towards zagred or anyone else
why was the devil so angry
specifically at dante i mean i don't
think this was just because of what
happened to gosh i think
it's deeper than that also when we saw
the anti-magic devil's face in the last
chapter
i can't be the only one who thought this
was aster for a second
but it's not esther this is just the
devil's face so the similarity looks
between the devil
astor and astor's mom coupled with the
fact that we now know that the devil
knew asda's mom
my guess is right now that the devil and
astor are related
and this devil is my theory right now
but this devil is possibly
his uncle if the rough translations are
accurate
then asda's mom tells the devil he's not
a bad guy
which is the type of language to me that
you'd expect from a sister to brother
relation
rather than a mother to son he's kind of
like casual you know
i don't i yeah that's what i think for
now let me let me know what you guys
think about that though
if the devil is astor's uncle then of
course he'd be filled with hatred and
rage towards dante
if it was him that killed his sister um
and you know maybe that death
led to negative mana surrounding the
devil and then maybe that's what turned
him into a devil
because at this point in the series we
still don't know exactly
what creates devils now there was a
panel in this chapter that maybe
explained what creates devils
but because it wasn't translated i
didn't get a i didn't really understand
what it was saying
um so maybe when the official
translation comes out we'll get an
explanation
but for now we don't know what creates
devils and so my assumption is
that this was created because of
negative mana
after his sister was killed by dante but
of course
that is just a theory and uh yeah we'll
just have to wait and see what happens
so uh be sure to subscribe as i have
another black clover video planned for
next week
as well as my hero and one punch man as
well we're doing it all we're doing
everything
so yeah be sure to subscribe and until
the next one
peace out